hello everyone and welcome to game
number six of the 1971 semi-final match
between bent Larsen and Bobby Fischer
now I hope you're having an excellent
Saturday and hopefully this game will
further improve your Saturday
that being said Ben Thorson is now in
kind of in the position marked Amano
found himself in if it's not the score
is now five to zero in Fischer's favor
and if he wants to at least draw this
match or to allow for playoffs he has
the now Larsen would have to win five
five of the next games in a row which is
highly unlikely because as we've already
mentioned this during the 1971 in 1970
Interzone all tournament in palma de
mallorca Bobby Fischer won seven of his
last games in a row there then he
continued by defeating mark time at
amount of six to zero and now he already
beat Ben force and five to zero so it is
very unlikely that a Fisher will now
lose five games in a row but you know it
could happen and we do have also I will
be using some of the comments by mikhail
tal from his shark a shark 64 magazine
also there will be a link to that in the
description below if you want to check
it out i found a nice article from
unchaste calm about it as someone
delivered all the news from the
newspapers there so that being said
let's check out this game so so far
Larson tried a lot of ideas now for the
final well for the sixth game he opens
with f4 he chooses the birds opening and
here tall says that now it's pretty much
clear that even Larsen came to terms
with who is the winner of this match so
perhaps he just wants to have fun
c5 was played Knight to f3 Fisher goes
g6e for Bishop to g7 and Bishop to e2
seems like a passive move with the
bishop but tell says that it's actually
the correct idea if you try something
like Bishop to c4 which seems like a
much more active move after a 6 b5 will
simply come with a tempo as it comes
with an attack on the bishop and it will
only help black so a nice move Bishop to
e2
nice to see six with castles d6 b3 e 6
and the knife to a3 it all says that
this is a
move very much characteristic you know
with Larsen style he wants to use well
well-known or opening lines and the
theory but also adds some of his own
original style
Knight to G to e7 by Fischer c3 I would
have castles the Bishop to e3 and now a
six
as you can see Fischer has a rock on a
eight perhaps the other local walls will
also join the Queen side this Bishop is
slicing the board all the way here and
Fischer will definitely want to resume
play on the Queen side by pushing the
pawns
so d4 here by Larson see chapters on d4
and now Knight captures on d4 also if
whites try something like see captors on
d4 to to get this message center then f5
will be a very nice idea by black and
black will be more than fine here
so after C captures we have a knight
capture Sun before and now b5 Fischer
simply continues with his plan of
playing on the Queen side
Knight captors on c6 Knight captures and
now comes our Queen to d2
Tull mentions that also possible is of
course Queen to e1 and transferring the
Queen over to the King side and starting
an attack against blacks King but you
know what what else would it all
suggests so Queen to d2 by Larson and
now Queen to c7 and here rook a to be 1
by Larson now you could argue that okay
perhaps going to c7 now the Queen is a
bit misplaced
maybe maybe an idea like f5 is worth
considering and it's definitely worth
considering but black wouldn't be in any
real danger here because after for
example captures captures and Bishop
captures let's say you even sacrifice in
exchange here G captures it's not all
that you know trivial how to continue
this attack group to f1 for example
maybe we want to get the rook in there
but then 95 comes you prevent prevent
the rook lift and black black would most
likely be okay here but I'm sure there
are there are plenty of people who would
actually go for this such a stall so
Queen to c7
we have rook a to D 1 but Larsson and
now comes hook to d8 we have nice to see
- and rook to b8 here tall says that
this is a really a bold move by Fischer
completely ignoring what Larsson is
trying to do here
as you can see the bish of the being and
c8 prevents the rooks from being
connected so e5 definitely a move you
have to take into consideration before
playing a move like rook to b8 but
Fischer doesn't care he goes rook to b8
and now we have a three again Larsen
says that well if Tao says that still I
move like Queen to e1 sorry I more like
Queen to e1 with transferring the Queen
over to the Kings side the would also be
worth considering you know why not start
an attack against Blacks King but okay
rook to b8 we have a three by Larsson
and now comes knife to a five by playing
this a three move Larson weakens the be
three square also nice the c-4 will be
an idea and the Fisher of course takes
advantage of this immediately
e5 Fisher decided that this was you know
not a problem for black so he allows it
bishop to f8 of course you cannot
capture because of Queen captures on d8
the so be sure to f8 defending and now B
for kicking the knight back here knife
the c-4 isn't all that great for black
after Bishop captures and Queen captures
you can simply go brush up to d4 to you
know solidify in the center and then
after night comes to e3 kicks away the
Queen White's position will be very nice
here so after be for Fisher simply goes
back Knight to c6 and here white is
pretty much forced to capture on d6 but
if you capture and Bishop captures then
blacks position is is beautiful here and
Larson will not be able to really do
anything here well I mean he can of
course always draw but a draw at this
point is worth nothing to him but even
though he could have afforded a draw in
Game five he decided not to go for a
draw in Game five either so okay after
this Knight to c6 by Fischer nice to d4
now as a draws out of question Larsen
decides to sacrifice a pawn and perhaps
try an attack Fischer scheme we have
four captures pawn captures and Fischer
grabs the pawn Knight captures on e5
Bishop to g5 attacking Fischer's rockin
d8 and now rook to d5 an excellent
defensive maneuver by Fischer because
Bishop to e7 would actually allow white
go for for something more after Bishop
captures Queen captures you get this
Queen to f4 move the the the night is
here attack you can't move the night
because the rocks aren't connected the
rockin b8 is undefended
so after rook to be 5 c4 and white black
loses the exchange for example captures
captures and now your rook is under
attack you if you move the rook you lose
the night so you have to capture here
and then Queen captures on b8 and you
would you would lose the exchange here
still it would be playable but you know
no reason to do this
so rook the d5 Fischer holds that holds
on to everything Queen to f4 again
pressuring pressuring the King side and
now we have Bishop to g7 Queen captures
on c3 is would it really have been a
bold move but there's there's no reason
to do it because after Bishop to f3 you
again lose the exchange here there's
really nothing to do even if you go
Knight captures on f3 would check you
get rook captures on f3 and now it's
even worse because your queen is under
attack you're getting crushed here Queen
captures on f7 is coming and you can't
defend with Queen c7 because the Queen
from f4 also guards the c7 square so
after Queen to f4 Bishop to g7 by
Fischer and now comes h4 we have rook to
b7 Fischer now gets a really nice idea
he wants to introduce more defenders to
the f7 square but also this will allow
his Queen to actually capture the pawn
on c3 so okay we have Bishop to f6
Bishop captures Queen captures and here
a lot of play a lot of people criticize
Fischer for this move because he is
already up in material he's already up a
pawn and he should have gone for
something like Queen to e7 this is what
everyone suggested but he just went for
Queen captures on c3
grabbing another pawn and now he allows
Larson to really start an attack Larson
plays h5 and here it's really not all
that clear now what you should do for
example if you try rock captors on d4
you get three captures on e5 rook the d3
you offer a trade of Queens but now
Queen to f4 rook captures rook captures
and after Bishop to d7 it's a pretty
pretty okay
game for both white and black white is
very active here no doubt say that he
could hold this to a draw on the other
hand after this h5 movement and not
capturing and before but for example
Queen to e3 which comes with protection
of the night here on e5 King gauge 1 and
now rook after sandy for it's not all
that great because of rook captures and
after Queen captures you get rook to d1
now you can't move the Queen because the
rook is coming to d8 and whatever you do
have to capture the rook here and give
up the Queen if you move the Queen then
even h6 is coming in - now there is no
defense against Queen to g7 checkmate
so after this h5 move Fischer actually
plays G captures on h5 a very nice idea
we have king - h1 a nice prophylactic
move and now comes knife to g4 forcing
forcing White's to capture the night we
have Bishop captures pawn captures and
now Queen to h6 if you try something
like rook to c1 I would an attack on the
Queen and the threat if the Queen moves
you will capture the bishop and see it
doesn't work because of rook to h5 check
a king moves and now Queen to e3 check
which comes with a check now if you
block with the rock you lose the rock
and c1 and of course if you block with
the Queen then you can simply exchange
Queens and it's it's all fine for black
Bishop to d7 is coming and you are
simply up three points easily winning an
endgame
so k/h captors on g4 Larsen goes Queen
to h6 Bishop to d7 by Fischer and the
now comes rook to f4 Larsen still is
playing for the win because s tal
mentions rook captures on f7 is a pretty
much a force to draw after King captures
the rook to f1 you have to block if you
move the king then Queen to f8 is coming
so you have to block and now simply
Queen captures on h7 King e8 you can go
Queen h8 check in get 7 - Queen here
King gauge a king yet Queen a trade King
f7 Queen to h7 okay you can never touch
the e7 square because then Knight to f5
comes with check and then white will
actually win this game now but still
after this Bishop to d7 by move by
Fischer rook captures an f7 is a is a
force to draw
Larsson a draw is pretty much the same
as a defeat
because in regards of who wins the match
of course so Luke 2:8 for by Larsson and
now f5 by Fischer still here after Queen
to g5 check of Larson could have drawn
this game for example King to f7 if King
to f7 then queen g4 and then black would
actually be in trouble as we'd have to
go King h8 and then again it would
result in a draw but like we said a
Larson has to go for the win so Queen to
f6
but now finger goes Bishop to c8 a nice
move with the best should be back and
now the Queen g5 will no longer achieve
a draw for white as Fischer can simply
bring the rook over into the defense
okay rook F back to F 1 we have rook to
f7 taking back the Queen Queen to h6
and now comes a bishop to b7 simply
putting this bishop on a beautiful
diagonal and now Fischer will start his
own attack Knight captures on e6 a very
nice idea but Fischer allowed this for a
reason Queen to f6 and the attack is
repelled now if you if you trade Queens
of course then rope captures rook
captures and d5 Bishop captures black is
up 2 points most likely most likely and
easily winning end game for Fischer
so after Queen to f6 Queen back to e3
was played rook to e7
now piling up on the night because it's
pinned rook to e1 and did not rook to d6
now with a triple attack against
Larsen's night so we have Queen to g5
check here Larsson forces the trade of
Queens but now it's far too late for
such things Queen captures Knight
captures rook captures rook captures and
rush up to d5 here Larsson played rook
to e8 check and here we have our King to
g7 and it was in this position unmoved
40 that bent Larsen resigned to the game
and Fischer won yet another match in the
candidate series with a result of 6 to 0
now before before I forget we do have
this photo it's a photo from the
newspapers there you can see it says
underneath
Grandmaster Bobby Fischer of the United
States studies the board before a move
as he downed went Larsen of Denmark
Tuesday night in the sixth and deciding
game of a ten game World Chess
Championship semi-final challenge series
Fisher forced Larsson to resign after 40
moves in winning his sixth straight over
the Danish champ so there you have it
also I will put a link to this photo in
the description if anyone wants to you
know learn more about it and as I don't
want to forget these are the standings
of the semi-finals so as you can see in
Denver Fischer defeated Larsson six to
zero so that match lasted only six games
and as you can see
Petrosyan unfortunately played the
entirety of the match so ten games were
played and you can see the final result
was five and a half to four and a half
where nine games were drawn and only one
game was won by Tigran Petrosian so
definitely a close match between
Petrosyan and Korchnoi and okay you
might argue that Petrosyan had a tougher
opponent that fortunately you know in
1971 was a tougher opponent then Larsson
but still five and a half to four and a
half and six to zero you it it's not all
that likely that Petrosyan
will be able to prevent Fisher from
pursuing his you know dream of becoming
world champion but as this is our next
stop in the series were definitely going
to enjoy that so yeah first you know
crushing the field in Palma the American
1917 then we we had a match would mark
tomorrow in Vancouver Canada that ended
six to zero then we have here in Denver
Colorado
again the Fisher you know presents
brilliant play with a result of six to
zero against the bent Larsen and now
after all of this has been played we
have the final match against Tigran
Petrosian so Fisheries off to Buenos
Aires to face the former world champion
so that's pretty much it for this game
it's very interesting I will once again
mention what about me Nick mentioned
about this entire event so before before
facing Petrosyan botanique says that
it's very easy to see how Fischer won
each one of his games so if you analyze
the games you can see that Fischer is
just a better player and it's a
pretty much clear hope you want every
game but it's very hard to imagine how
he won all the games 12 to 0 but when he
does mention Lasker's for example great
results you know against against
Marshall and the Janoski
and those were really really one of the
most impressive results in chess history
you know match wise but still it was not
a hundred percent against two of the
strongest grandmasters in the world like
Fischer did here so this was
unprecedented and everyone knew that but
winning even mentions his encounter with
Fischer in the Varna Olympiad when
Fischer wasn't even twenty years old yet
and bottoming says that he what he
played Fischer he understood that this
is some you know great chess force in
front of him even though he was such a
such a young lad but I bought when he
said that it was definitely not
botanique who was deciding the tone of
the battle and the ha how this was going
to turn out he said that Fischer was
better at everything in that game and
you know because he was better in in
combinations that he achieved a winning
position if you haven't seen that game
oh I will also put a link to that game
in the description below as it's the
only game ever played between Bobby
Fischer and Mikhail Botvinnik so that's
that's pretty much it I do hope you
enjoyed this match this and that you're
still enjoying the the Bobby Fischer
series next stop it's Buenos Aires and
it's the match finals of the 1971
candidates Bobby Fischer vs. Tigran
Petrosian so I would like to thank
Bettany love Chris Durant far shot every
Nia and Ryuga and Dustin young as poor
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot I really appreciate it as
usual you can check two of my previous
videos here thank you for watching and
I'll see you soon most likely starting
the Fisher versus Petrosyan match thank
you all and I'll see you soon